okay hello everyone it's Michael BOS
here from order flows.com and this is
the orderflows market analysis from
Friday March 17 2017 before I get
started a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures training continues to St a risk
and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results tools that I use in this
presentation are the orderflows trader
the volto flip the volto U-turn and the
volto transition um if I got time I'll
I'll pop in a couple other ones but real
quick first up uh let me show you this
new indicator that been working on for a
while it's it's called the uturn and
it's something that it measures areas in
the market
where buyers and sellers I don't want to
say buyers and sellers contradict each
other but it's it's looking for turning
points in the market you know people
always say don't try to pick highs and
lows
and this isn't something to pick highs
and lows rather it's picking areas where
you know the market is turning right I
always like to find areas where Market's
turning and I use the volto U-turn to
help me find the areas where Market's
turning now notice it's not picking
every single Turning Point um you know
going back to 700 in the morning you got
a signal here up to this signal here now
this is three range chart so it's moving
a little quick in some areas like this
one is moving pretty quick um then
you're catching this next swing High
here notice it doesn't give you a buy
here um you know people think that you
know hey orderflow analysis should give
you every single turn in the market no
you know sometimes you know the markets
just make its natural Curves in the
market I'll say turns but you know the
market fluctuates right markets exist to
facilitate
trade
and you know so you're going to get even
you're going to get um you know orderly
transitions from um demand driven
markets to supply driven markets and
vice versa but there are times where
order flow will signal out turning
points in the market as it's happening
and this is an indicator that we've
programmed to help find those areas
where the market is just sort of
stopping and and trying to turn around
now you'll notice you know here this
trade didn't work out
okay you know you had one nice winner
another nice winner here and these
negligible um and that was it on the
U-turn for that day on
Friday uh this was the bonds gave a
signal you had three signals this is
also the U-turn gave a signal here um a
buy early 7:30ish around there you know
went from 148 even up to around the 08
level gave a sell which one this one
didn't work out okay and you should have
a stop you know stop you out this one is
at the end of the day you know not
every signal is going to be a winner
you're going to have some winners you're
going to have some losers that's trading
um again you if you're trying to find an
area where the Market's possibly turning
you're not always going to be 100% right
you know again I'm not trying to pick
highs and lows or anything like that but
I'm looking for areas where you know you
sort of have an inflection point where
it's changing you know it's it's
turning okay moving on this is the
transition transition you know it also
measures order flow but in a slightly
different way than the U-turn again it's
also trying to find a market that's
transitioning from buyers to sellers or
sellers to
buyers give a signal here again you know
I'm I'm I'm showing you the whole day
you know you can see there's no signals
there so I'm not trying to just
cherry-pick a certain spot out um you
can see there's no sells there's just a
couple of buys here this one started to
work out then it came down here I mean
it Market didn't find its bottom yet
before starting to rally and that's
that's how it goes sometimes it's you
know thought it on its low for the day
or you know at least a swing
low but still had a little selling
pressure in there left before it rallied
up okay this one um you know sort of not
going to get into it but you know this I
don't think is is a decent signal
because you know I I like to let the
market take me into the trade if the
next bar can't even break the high of
the bar with the signal you shouldn't be
taking the trade you know the Market's
not giving you any confirmation that
it's
changing okay this next one is the uh
PLC Trader not so much but more
importantly The Flip Flip is not one I
really talk about is it's not really
designed for all Traders it's really
designed for really shortterm Traders a
bit on the scalping side again um he's
trading mini D it's a five range it's a
very quick moving
chart and again it's a very tight uh I
say tight indicator it's an indicator
designed more for extreme shorter term
Traders so you get a buy here this one
didn't work out then you got a sell
which worked out nicely here a nice
little buy popped up for a few points um
got another sell here down in here a
little bit of a buy that worked out a
little bit um again you know this one
was designed for more short-term trading
um you know people that are just trying
to get a few ticks here
there you this one here didn't work out
again that's one of those should you be
taking the trade no I don't think so
because you know what you didn't get any
sort of confirmation on the on the next
bar um late in the day just after the
cash close um nice little trade to end
out the day now those you these are
again you know these are these three
indicators here boom flip you turn
transition it's part of my inner circle
um or if you know I had a special if you
bought the package but um you know
people always ask about it and you know
I I just want to show charts about them
U before I sort of jump into the normal
order flow charts you know not everybody
is is on board with trading with
orderflow um you know looking at a chart
trying to decipher it like this is a b
chart and I can see here at 834 you know
this is a perfect example on why we
should how a market turns you're coming
down D do do working your way down you
get an area here of you know some heavy
volume 1,600
2,000 you know on this way down look at
the size of the bids 700 400 300 you
know people then you get down here you
got you got a buyer here basically
saying you know what I'll take all that
you got to sell you notice how this is
where the market just happens to make
that short-term turn at uh 159 52 53
area um all the way up to you know 60s
that that's quick 10 ticks right there
um then again you know you
got whoops you got some got some other
things here you know you had a three in
a row I do like to get a pullback here
it didn't
happen uh but you know you kept going up
up up but again you know this was a sign
here we got ratio ratio ratio that's
what you like to see on a market that's
moving okay so the next one I want to
talk about is is the NASDAQ um this is
interesting this is something you see
practically every single
day in one market or another and what it
is is you're rallying up to your high
this is a 10 range NASDAQ chart railing
right up into your high you hit your
high and what you're watching here is
the Delta right the Delta is a net
difference between the buyers and
sellers in the bar and you see right at
this High what do you got you've got a
high you got a Divergence so you have
negative Delta at a new High new or
equal High big strong negative Delta
okay if you're not convinced that this
is your high yet you know wait to see in
the next bar what how it shapes up to be
and again it's more selling coming in I
mean you know I could pull up chart
after chart after chart of of highs that
are made with um you know strong
negative Delta and then the market sells
off now not every time you have that
it's going to sell off but there's
certain Clues in here that you could
pick up I'm not going to get into all of
that but you know again if if you're not
convinced in this bar you know wait for
the next bar okay again more selling not
convinced yet wait for the next bar more
selling what happens it just keeps going
down down down down down you know I mean
you know the way these uh this Market's
been the equities markets have been in
the last couple months is you get a lot
of late nice late moves in the day and
if you can you know have a reason to be
looking to buy or sell you know near
high or a low you know go for it you
know again you know this is this is a
low that we made at 1010 came down here
you do have a
Divergence okay again you know it's
smallest Delta 88 fair enough but you
know what's important is you know you're
hanging around these lows making new
lows but you you're seeing you know some
buying starting to come in here here and
here and here you got the positive Delta
okay maybe you're not convinced then you
get to this bar you know minus 18 okay
that's that's relatively small you know
18 Lots in some of these contracts maybe
the NASDAQ you know that the difference
of one trade
maybe you know if someone else spot
another 20 Lots it'd be positive Delta
so you know that's what I consider kind
of a neutral Delta
number then here you got a nice strong
Delta you got a ratio you got a blue
number here that you like nice strong
Delta you know and again you're just
sort of hanging around this low um you
come down here you got a negative a
positive Delta okay here you got a
negative
Delta but why do you have a negative
Delta is because you've got some strong
selling into the bid side here so I know
that you know I'm down here at the low
I've got a bar that's turning up got a
bullish ratio that's telling me there's
some absorption going on in this low
area down in here again you know it's
giving me some signs that you know the
market could start to Rally then boom
you get this bar here nice strong
positive Delta so I've already got you
know a few things you know I've
got you know I've got a Divergence here
I've got some signs of you know some
some volume buying volume down here just
off the low and then here I got a nice
strong positive Delta for me it's a you
know fasten your seat belt get ready to
go and you know what the market do it
literally rallied over the next couple
hours from you know from the low all the
way up uh you know almost straight I say
straight up to our high but um it got up
to our high with you know just one
little
pullback okay so the next Market I want
talk about is the bonds um you know just
sort of to follow up with that NASDAQ
right I was talking about the NASDAQ
where you had the high you had the
negative Delta and it's like hey all
signs are there that's going to sell off
now you know not always does it happen
here you you run into your highs here
around just for 8:00 all negative Deltas
you got a Divergence here
641 then it doesn't sell off it comes
back it makes new high makes new high
you know that's sometimes that's the
reality of trading you could have the
best best indicator in the world you get
short but you know if you don't have
that you know the trade so to speak you
know the people coming in behind you to
keep the market moving in that direction
after you get short if you don't have
sellers coming in to keep selling then
the Market's not going to go down but
you know what are the
signs well like I said you know you have
the Divergence you know be careful
taking divergences alone you know I like
to wait to see how things shape up in
the next bar okay and what do you got in
the next bar the bar turns up it's small
negative Delta of 17 again you know
negative 17 is is very small it's a
difference of you know one or two trades
could easily easily be positive Delta if
there was just you know another 18 Lots
on the offer there for someone to trade
you know maybe it just wasn't at that
time um because this is a range bar so
but anyway you know that's you know kind
of an a bad sign right there um I said
you know just because you have one bar a
Divergence a new high with a negative
Delta you know don't take them blindly
you know wait wait for some confirmation
to show up and you don't get it and then
you just keep going higher higher higher
positive
Deltas go sideways here another new high
some more new highs um this is a dogee
bar here there's no
Divergence I for me for
orderflow when I see a dogee bar I don't
I don't ignore it but in terms of my
analysis the only thing I really analyze
is the Delta other than that I don't
make or tals of the numbers inside the
bar um and then then later again you get
another Divergence here and it's
followed up with the dogee it's it's one
big down candle very strong negative
Delta but it's Mac DOI DOI on both sides
you know what what can you do um this
bar sort of comes back here you then
late in the day you get another
Divergence um which sort of does nothing
as the Market's closing Friday afternoon
yeah so this day was it was kind of see
difficult but you know you weren't
getting the best uh the best reads in
the market you know we all like we all
like days where things you know just
really fall into place quite nicely but
then there's days where you know where
things just don't don't present
themselves you know in a nice orderly
fashion um you know there's nothing you
can do about it I mean you can't slam
slam orderflow for it it's not order
flow's fault but
uh you know I said you can only trade
with the what the Market's giving you
you know just real quick another short
quick example is is a Bund again I'm
going back to the Buns this is a
15minute
chart order flow on a 15minute chart
is it's not something a lot of people do
but you know people still look at it and
you know on here you got a couple
divergences what happens you got this
first Divergence Market went up made a
new high by uh a couple of t and then
made the sell off
so it's it's you know it's one of those
things right you know Market's looking
for a high sometimes or a low and in
this case it's looking for a high and it
just hasn't quite found it yet it's
still got another high to make before it
makes that sell off again um you know
what's important is got the high very
strong negative Delta still made a new
high and the Delta
still negative okay that's not as strong
as the first one but then even the next
one negative Delta negative Delta you
know again it's debatable if you should
be even trading buns at 12:00 Chicago
time but you know it was giving the
signs of you know a weaker
Market okay now real quick again this is
a uh fiveyear chart I say again but this
is a 5-year chart
and you know 900 in the morning 8: in
the morning you had a Divergence said
failed right 850
here but you know why it fail I mean you
can see the buying came right back in
the next bar again it's just a naked
Divergence by itself now what I'm going
to show you is something that can help
you filter out your divergences to find
more profitable ones get another
Divergence right here 921 you got
negative Delta look how it comes back
with the dogee and just go
sideways then here 1056 you got this
Divergence
big strong negative Delta but look at
this number 9354 now you know if you're
familiar with my software one of the
things that it does is it I I do it give
you a calculation you know that's what
these numbers above or below you know
below for up bar above for a red bar
down bar so you know the bar opened here
closed here so we put the number on top
you know for
visuals this bar opened here closed up
here put the number below cuz it's a
bullish bar right it's a green candle
it's an up candle closed higher than
what we opened so I want to be analyzing
the order flow towards the bottom of the
bar just as on a bar that's heading down
I want to analyze the volume at the top
of the bar you know for either price
rejection or Price
absorption so here you have a ratio not
a ratio you here you have a Divergence
you got your new high with a negative
Delta and then in the next bar right
look to the next bar for confirmation I
often say that what do you got you've
got a a blue number which is is
indicating a bearish ratio it's bearish
because it's onp it's a blue number on
on Top This is a bullish one CU it's a
blue number underneath this one's just a
a a normal order flow related number you
know there's nothing special nothing
special at this one but this one you get
it so it's telling you hey you know it's
the type of number it's what I call
ratio bounds High indicating price
rejection because it's above a certain
level a certain
threshold and what's the market do the
next bar boom sells off some more um
again sells off some more here then you
reach down here you've got um you know a
bullish ratio but you know you've had a
nice move from you know the
11705 and A2 down a 4 and a half that's
four tick move in the in the 5
years okay the last one I want to talk
about uh today I don't want to make this
video too
long is this is the soybeans soybeans is
great
contract and
I say great contract I mean great
contract trade you know a lot of people
made fortunes trading
soybeans so don't disregard it because
it's not as glamorous as say crude oil
or anything like that and you know
coming down into the lows making new
lows Divergence here Divergence here
that fail that fail rather quickly one
here fails to the next bar one here
fails in the next bar new lows new lows
but you know look as you get down into
this low here you know this is
information in the order flow that you
only order flow gives you right if
you're trading on a normal bar chart
you're not going to be picking up that
this Market's turning
here and what do you get you got this
low you got a stacked selling imbalance
here even the next bar you got still
selling IM balance still selling balance
we're just going sideways here haven't
been able to break out from this low
here at 994 and a quar but look at the
selling it's quite strong here - 596 -
220 getting weaker - 173 it's getting
weaker now it's positive it's
buying where's my mouse it's now it's
gone from net negative selling net more
selling to net buying 2 plus 268 plus
102 plus 361
so where's your selling pressure you
don't have it there anymore instead
you've got net buying pressure coming in
and what does the market do it rallies
off that low again you this is only
information you're going to get from an
orderflow chart that if you're you're
not using orderflow charts in your in
your analysis I mean you're you're just
leaving a great tool on the
table you know it's a nice move say even
get it get long from here 997 and a half
you know way up here um you know it
makes a move all the way
up comes down a little bit you know 999
still just sort of hanging around there
you know a late
move you know right before the close so
you know that that's a nice 3 Cent move
could have got
well at least two cents out of the move
but um you know two cents in the
soybeans is already uh is already 100
bucks on one lot so you know two cents
in the soybeans is like two points in
the
S&P and you don't have to fight all
these stupid elos and all this stuff
that's going on in that market there are
elos that trade in the beans but it's
not as uh prevalent or intense as it is
trading the uh trading the snps so again
um you know thanks for watching this if
you want to learn more about trading
with orderflow and the software using
this presentation visit my website www.
orderflows decom so thanks and see you
on the
inside